[Blood Diamond] Do you ever think when you're dead,
what it's going to be like for people to see this?
[Blood Diamond] It's like it's 2120, and people look at it and they're like,
"What the fuck is Synth Pop?"
[Narration] H∆SHTAG$, a discussion on internet music phenomenon, digital culture.
[Narration] In this episode we talk about the idea of "Blog Pop"
with pop princess Charli XCX, genre benders,
[Narration] AlunaGeorge, post-mart duo, Teengirl Fantasy,
and third floor cream, Katy B.
[Ruth Saxelby] The idea of what has pop is definitely shifted over the last few years
to stretch the idea of what pop is,
[Ruth Saxelby] and they're all working across a world of different genres.
[Charli XCX] This is this tumblr called "In Real Life" London,
and they designed these leggings that I'm wearing right now,
[Charli XCX] taking the internet and putting it on clothes.
I want my mind to be like the inside of my mind
is meant to kind of look like my tumblr, you know.
[Charli XCX] The artists who are kind of like doing the whole like online thing
and they're embracing it, and they're not embarrassed to be associated with that,
[Charli XCX] the reason is because they were made by the internet.
[Charli XCX] I was born into it.
I just use all of that data and vomit out creatively what the kind of product of that is,
kind of like mixing that with my own self.
[Ruth Saxelby] It's more about internet behaviour than it is about internet genre.
The music has changed, but also our ideas of the names and the fixed things
that used to be don't have the same kind of boundaries anymore.
[Katy B] Pop music has always come from like an underground raw place,
that line is blurring more now than it's ever done.
[Teengirl Fantasy] Pop's definition has totally been shattered and people can release any type of song
and it can become popular because it can be distributed to thousands of people instantly.
[Ruth Saxelby] Taking it on face value and knitting it into this collage style music that draws on so much,
that's a very natural thing that human beings do.
[AlunaGeorge] Take all the bits that were good and put them all together and make a new song.
That's what I'm doing.
[AlunaGeorge] We first met on the internet.
I don't think we'd exist without post-mart, I would give.
[AlunaGeorge] Nowadays, pop music tends to be what people pass on to each other because of the internet.
It just really widens your possibilities.
[AlunaGeorge] There is that kind of infinite possibility with computers,
you're learning what you're hearing.
[AlunaGeorge] Come back in, I'm going to do something in there.
(song) City of white, torn by the sea, you'll be in you.
[AlunaGeorge] I guess, features are...
[AlunaGeorge] When art had a massive time with modernism, you know,
they had to be this description of a massive shift in music.
[AlunaGeorge] Maybe the future makes more sense than the past.
[Teengirl Fantasy] To me, it's not even a question,
I think it's all online pop, it's pop now.
[Ruth Saxelby] I think the internet is almost like the mainstream now,
rather than the underground.
[Katy B] I think that they have always been, you know,
the diggers and the people that will stay in record shops looking for things for hours on end.
[Katy B] Maybe they've just evolved into digital age.
[Blood Diamond] Pop music has become kind of this, like, over-and-composing thing of, like,
dance and electronic and indie bits.
[Blood Diamond] And, you know, it's just, like, one big thing now.
(Music)
[Ruth Saxelby] Because people just want to hear stuff that they can believe in,
[Ruth Saxelby] whether it's a ballad or some crazy, you know, dance floor hit.
(Music)
[Charli XCX] Their life kind of is the internet these days.
[Charli XCX] So, I guess, they're equally important.
[Charli XCX] I think it's nice to have a sense of, like, there is, like, you know,
a real thing.
[Charli XCX] Like, love, you know?
[Charli XCX] Like, I'd always pick love over cyber love, you know?
[Charli XCX] So, I guess, I'm going to pick real life over the internet.
(Music)